[Música]
cómo se encuentra
cómo está la gente de arriba
[Música]
los amigos del centro
excelente
me alegro mucho saben ustedes que lo más
importante de cada día para nosotros
como seres humanos es sonreír saben por
qué y saben más allá porque sonreír es
más importante antes de hacerlo creernos
en cuenta nosotros porque el ser humano
es como los imanes por donde quiera que
yo pase me los voy jalando tengo la
facilidad de llevarme los por lo bueno
por lo malo saben ustedes
qué imagen es la que está aquí atrás
alguno la recuerda
para algunos el famoso cartucho la calle
del terror para mí fue mi casa fue mi
hogar pero en 1999 a finales del año
conocí a un gran ser humano conoce un
angelito llamado javier de nicoló que me
dio la oportunidad de salir de ahí me
enseñó las bases como el amor la
confianza me enseñó lo más importante
que para sacar a los seres humanos de
sus dificultades hay que darles
herramientas
y eso lo empecé a aplicar en la vida
después de haber salido de allá me
empeñé en trabajar con los jóvenes
y lo hice ahora la intervención del
bronx fue un reto más para por medio del
arte sacarlos de ahí y nació esta idea
con los pilares que me enseñó el padre
una idea sencilla una idea que no
necesita una plataforma para funcionar
una idea que no muere si se cae en las
redes sociales
una idea que así no lo crean no necesita
tener esto lleno no necesita tener el
bolsillo lleno sabe que tiene que tener
esta idea para que funcione corazón
y esa idea fue sencilla montar algo bajo
tres hermosos pilares el primer pilar es
el amor
que va acompañado de enseñar a la
juventud cómo superar las adversidades
ese es el primer paso el segundo la
confianza y la confianza viene
acompañada de algo muy importante para
nosotros
los procesos sociales
las redes sociales pero cuando hablo de
red social en nuestro hablando facebook
no hablo de eso hablo de esto redes
sociales
algo más allá que nos da la oportunidad
nosotros de ser mejores personas
y el tercero de todos uno de los más
importantes los instrumentos las
herramientas de desarrollo en mi caso
fue esta guitarra el primer instrumento
que me regaló el padre para desarrollar
mi cambio social pero como la calle
todos los días evoluciona nosotros
tenemos que evolucionar con ella
y entregarle a los jóvenes diversidad de
cosas para que cambien sus vidas
la idea es muy sencilla las artes como
eje de transformación social la palabra
lo dice todo como los jóvenes por medio
de las artes pueden sacar
de su cabeza la adicción
cómo pueden sacar ese dolor como a
través de las artes pueden liberar su
alma muy sencillo
empecé ahí tales talleres a ellos en la
calle enseñándoles lo más importante y
lo que hace verídico esta idea que me la
enseñaron a mí y sabe por qué es tan
real porque aquí hay un ejemplo vivo que
si funciona hablarle a los jóvenes el
lenguaje de la calle esa es la clave
hábleles como ellos entienden como ellos
ven el mundo pero él es herramientas
para que puedan cambiar
les enseñe que las artes pueden sacarlos
adelante dictándoles talleres de edad
urbana
enséñale también al mundo que no siempre
me tiene que patear a mí votarme al
asfalto está de hecho pateo el piso yo
pateo el mundo me le tiré y me giro en
la cabeza
le enseño como por medio del teatro
puedes sacar todas esas imágenes de un
pasado reprimido en su corazón
pueden ser los dueños de su propia
historia y cambiar ese tipo de
represiones de abusos que muchas veces
inicia desde sus casas como por medio
del graffiti podemos cambiar ese estigma
de que todos los grafiteros son vándalos
que lo vean como delincuentes ja ja qué
bonito nos rayes a paredes
ah qué bonito no se tire esto que no sea
símbolo de violencia al contrario que
sea círculo
de cultura símbolo de paz para ellos
mismos y la mejor y la más importante de
todos la música entonces yo les digo a
ellos oiga está cansado esto está
cansado que lo para tiene en la esquina
está cansado que lo discriminen por
tener tatuajes está cansado que lo
discriminan por no ser nadie por no ser
bachiller porque es blanco negro gordo
flaco que se tome tome un cuaderno
escriba redacte aprenda hágalo la mejor
manera de cachetear al mundo es hacerlo
con diplomacia con la música sin un solo
sin una sola grosería pueden hacer ellos
que todo el mundo se entere de lo que
está pasando realmente que logramos con
esta idea algo muy sencillo
- jóvenes en las calles menos adicto a
la droga y más adictos a esto
al arte
- mamás llorando en su casa pidiendo la
diosa y dónde estará mi hijo
cierto y todo el mundo dice así tiene
razón y la mayoría dice ojalá pero como
esto solamente le duele a uno cuando le
llega a la casa
desafortunadamente es que no tenía un
familiar drogadicto que haya caído en
alguna calamidad dice a mí nunca pero él
ya que les toca ahí no voy a decir que
es familiar esto no es esta vaina los
conflictos sociales no respetan estratos
no respetan si usted es blanco si es
gordito si es alto en cualquier momento
le llega y es ahí cuando yaya y venga no
conoce alguna fundación que ayude a
alguien que hable es mejor hacerlo ahora
y ese es el resultado sacar chicos de la
calle por medio de que de las artes
ahora yo les digo ustedes
le puedo poner un ejemplo sencillo si
usted va por la calle
y se encuentra una persona pero mal muy
mal triste y le pidió una moneda algo de
comer para que lo ayuden le rompe el
corazón cuántos de ustedes levanten la
mano le ayudarían a esa persona en la
calle en el transmilenio con una moneda
sean sinceros levanten la mano puesto lo
harían
excelente cuánto le daría un pedazo de
pan algo de comer levanten la mano
excelente quiero que salga en un aplauso
fuerte fuerte o fuerte un aplauso
pero no es la manera
tienen un corazón muy grande pero esa no
es la manera de ayudar usted le da una
moneda a la persona en la calle le da un
pan los convierte en asistencialistas el
primer día y le rompe el corazón el
segundo y el tercero tiene un amigo de
por vida
ya no vuelve a trabajar porque sabe que
la moneda la tiene con usted a las 8 de
la mañana y el pan a las nueve y media
con la señora que pasa y se convierte en
el mejor amigo suyo pero le está robando
la oportunidad de cambio quiere ayudarlo
de las herramientas para que salga
adelante oiga enseñarle cómo se hace un
pan enseñarle cómo cuánto cuesta y sudor
ganarse una moneda ese es el es el tipo
de cambio que nosotros necesitamos ahora
yo le digo a qué viene todo esto cuál es
el gran reto
después de hacer intervenciones en uno y
el otro lado el crédito se llama la
calle del bronx
bronze distrito creativo linda palabra
en que la van a convertir ahora yo
pregunto será que va a ser lo mismo que
hicieron con la hacienda nápoles mamá
paleface donde todo el mundo llega como
si esto fuera una payasada va a ser un
icono de maldad yo a seguir siendo un
icono de maldad o vamos a sentar cabeza
y vamos a hacer que esto sea un lugar
de paz pero de paz para los jóvenes de
paz para el corazón de artes donde por
medio de cualquier tipo de arte ellos
puedan sanar su alma que no sea un lugar
que en sus tiempos pasados fue alterado
por la violencia que cuando alguien lo
vea cuando un extranjero y los
residentes pasen diga oiga mire vea esos
chinos como bailan como pintan que sea
un lugar que bajo la melodía de las
artes en medio de las tonadas tristes
y alegres los hizo libres
sean libres ustedes todo el mundo puede
ser un profesor cómo funciona cómo
funciona esta idea cómo funciona esta
escuela
funciona sin ningún peso sin ningún
recurso
lo hice yo sin ningún recurso excepto el
recurso humano acabe o diez mil
corazones diez mil ideas
pero cuando les hablan de dinero el
bolsillo les duele
y la mejor manera de aportar muchas
veces no es dinero usted puede ser un
héroe usted puede ser un educador un
profesor simplemente regalando una hora
de su tiempo para enseñar a los demás y
no necesariamente yo tengo que ser
un profesional en lo que hago tener un
diploma el profe saben por qué me dicen
el profe porque me gane la confianza y
dejaron quedarme con un maestro me ven
como un amigo y los que ayudan en esa
escuela en esta idea son nada más que
los papás los tíos que no son
profesionales pero quieren voluntad
regalar dos horas diarias de su trabajo
para enseñarles a ellos que el cambio
está ahí las reflexiones de ustedes
esa es la idea no necesita plataformas
que se vaya a la luz esto sigue
les dejo este en el corazón vayan
pensando que quieren hacer con sus vidas
y no esperen que esto le llegue a la
puerta de su casa listos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
quiero que escuchen
por qué
las artes cambian corazones
[Música]
guillén
e
[Música]
ah
desde la 19
bolívar
[Música]
ahora vienes con el cuento de que no
sabías lleva fumando a sus nueve años de
tu vida llevas tu costal a lucro también
una cobija cargas el trofeo del
para abajo para arriba es sorprendida
era lo que tú querías desde hace un paso
nunca te dominaría y ahora mira lo que
hiciste con tu vida atrofiarse un
cerebro por fuma esta porquería pero no
es tarde para que salgas del conflicto
no olvides que en el cielo hay un dios
hay un amigo que a ti te escucha y
perdonar los errores y está en tu
corazón pero no para que te toque
es el camino hacia una vida de cambio
escuché el testimonio de lo que hubiera
logrado nadie dijo que la paz y
levantarse cuando está abajo con
dedicación con estero es que no lo grabó
entonces para porque no puedes hacerlo
existe un solo dios para no tanto si los
negros
[Música]
no olvides de mi hermano porque cuando
hay salida vive el servicio hay cosas
que son mejores empieza por la carpa que
tu madre ya no llores
[Música]
para que se sienta sola que viaje tiene
un hijo que la quiere y que la adora
estas son cosas que vale más que el
dinero el amor de una madre el cariño
verdadero la dicha de ver crecer a tus
hijos
sabes que eres ejemplo malo pero si
usted basta con todo lo que tengo
ahogado en el vicio pero después no
vengas cuando la lluvia
con hermanos mira los años pasan estas
una nueva vida
sentado escuchando lo que digo
por eso es que yo no
a mi madre que yo tenía de capacitarte
con yo me decía el padre jamás
[Música]
por qué
para sacar a los jóvenes de las calles
[Música]
[Aplausos]
ah
y esa cláusula
para ustedes
o regalarse esta hermosa tarde
lleguen a sus casas y multiplíquenlo yo
ya hice mi parte diez mil corazones una
misma idea yo los bendiga
[Aplausos]